together they lived happily ever after
okay
there you go
oh
[ __ ] oh here he is now the party here
start
welcome back to new rock stars marvel
studios what if episode seven was a
party that comes to an abrupt end or an
abrupt beginning with infinity stone
powered ultravision but really for nerds
like us that's when the party begins
like dance music vandalism yawn but give
us some sympathoids with some big bang
gems
this is inside marvel our after show for
marvel's what if on disney plus i'm eric
voss thank you so much to mt last week
recovering the breakdown for me uh you
did a great job i loved that video
but i'm back on breakdown duty this week
and tomorrow's video with all the easter
eggs you missed is coming to the channel
tomorrow but right now i'm talking about
this episode 7 with mt
mt a thoughts man it was a party for
sure we had a lot of cameos from
different like people from different
areas of the marvel universe my mind was
exploding when the sovereign showed up
to party because those guys are just
notoriously just like i hate everybody
else so they're just like oh man this
party is really good so if the
sovereignty showed up that's a good part
it's like going to a party be like whoa
you got those snobs to come right you
got the nerds to leave the
library you got everybody it felt like
kind of like what uh a stefan
description was from the snl stuff on
stitch
we got hired the duck we got
this song
we got grandmaster and his little topaz
oh my god freaking they even brought the
weapon that melted that guy to the party
yeah that's hilarious
we got clancy brown as certain melting
statue of liberty mr krabs back assert i
love that i love that so much he melted
her arm off he was like oh [ __ ]
well in a universe where odin never
adopted loki and instead returned him to
the frost giants thor became essentially
logan paul and parties it up on earth
as odin goes into odin's sleep i also
love how frigga's like i'm going with
the girls we're gonna drink uh
chardonnay to celebrate the solstice
which has got a party too now i think
odin had the best idea here because as
someone who despises loud parties i'd
rather just have a nice nap i think odin
had the best plan so i could just be
about running a partier i wanted to
follow odin what was odin dreaming about
what if odin had odin dreams and odin's
sleep why don't we cut to the dreams i
just wanted to see what happens he
sleeps
i know we read charges energy i just
wanted to know um but jane foster and
darcy joined the party in vegas uh and
it's filled with mcu cameos we got core
grand master topaz scourge yondu drax
rocket mantis surter the sovereign and
aisha and more darcy freaking mary's
howard the duck
congratulations darcy good choice very
very nice man yeah we were joking that
like we also wanted to see what married
life between darcy and howard the doc
was yes it would be so hilarious and
probably very contentious
like uh howard's like no i don't want to
explore adoption and darcy's like how
could you even say that there are so
many kids who need to be adopted right
now and they just get divorced and
then laura dern shows up and says look
you're deserved some of that grant money
and how are the duck just punches a hole
in the wall and then uh he goes i'm
sorry i'm sorry it just clutches her
ankles
and then uh darcy takes half of the
bread obviously yes when you're out of
luck divorce a duck divorce the duck
well loki shows up in this episode as a
fully fledged frost giant and empty
that did things to me that i'm not ready
to talk about oh okay i mean i don't
think you're alone there because twitter
went ablaze went ablaze for frost giant
loki good guy yikes uh well shield steps
in um maria hill as acting secretary or
acting director as a
fury was knocked out of
the
world
cannons uh and then um maria hill
summons carol danvers to knock thor
around the globe i love these big looney
tunes styles right names on the map
it was very road runner today
yeah uh-huh and then uh thor wins round
one and shames carol danvers
loser
and then shield decides to just try to
nuke thor but jane reaches heimdall and
frigga friga scolds thor and then thor
like ferris bueller style rushes to
clean up the planet
before she gets back and then thor sets
up a date with jade but a portal opens
to a squad of ultron drones led by
ultravision is what we're calling them
here he's armed with all six infinity
stones
empty this is huge
yes we saw ultravision on the poster for
the series along with shots of ultron
sentries and trailers so the guy's
coming back this is our first uh
crossover confirmation on what if the
anthology structure is officially over
we're on the continuity train so we
gotta talk about how ultravision came to
be and what he's doing next that's we're
gonna talk about this episode but first
uh you are running out of time to grab a
what if latest obsession shirt at
newrockstarsmerch.com as the show winds
down so does the availability of our
limited supply shirt there's also two
really cool shang cheese shirts
available and you get a really great
discount if you buy them both at the
same time i didn't know that
wow i didn't know that either
it's like multiple for one i don't know
what the deal is check out the website
newaxesbush.com but if you get the what
if latest obsession shirt you'll get the
option to leave a custom shout out that
runs during inside marvel what do we
have here let's see katie carl says eric
who would star as peggy and rogers the
musical oh
who would star as peggy uh sutton foster
has uh is a pretty great talent uh
christy carl said romano oh my god let's
get your possibility belle and beauty
and the beast i think she'd make a great
peggy uh i think what we'd need like a
british uh star right i don't i don't
know enough
uh recent british uh west end stars just
get any of the cast of the six i think
could handle that having i don't know
their names but they're
freaking great let's see uh d'angelo
asks in a multiversal twist what if
killmonger has a character arc and
becomes our new black panther in the mcu
this is what a lot of people have been
like like speculating or like even
hoping to see like killmonger like a
multiverse of kim monger come in and
replace black panther i don't think that
they'll do that i just think that
killmonger was a villain in black
panther one and like they're
reestablishing that he was a villain in
this whatever series so like it'd just
be weird just be like all right now he's
good and now he's leading wakanda uh
yeah it doesn't feel right to me either
i mean he died and his death was a
pretty important death i think if uh you
were to ever like i think it's possible
people theorize different ways uh um
killmonger could be reanimated or
brought back to life you know through
the atlanteans or something like that
right um i just think his death had some
great weight and some great meaning oh
so much black panther and i and it'd be
weird to see michael b jordan just kind
of come back however if a multiverse is
coming there's all kinds of new things
they could do with characters bringing
them back et cetera so uh we'll see i
just don't know if this particular arc
will be the route they would go um
but james yaw asks i still go back and
watch the miss minutes jump scare
reaction video in the loki finale she
got both of you yes she did and i am
looking around every corner for miss
smith i was so unafraid the entire time
i don't even know what you're talking
about james i don't know what you're
talking about and my pants are still wet
i don't have continents anymore because
of miss minutes
uh well empty what's our first question
coming out of this episode well eric
what if ultravision is the ultimate
villain of the series and like where the
hell did ultravision even come from yeah
so ultravision is coming back because we
saw him on the poster and in trailer
footage ultron sentries are mowed over
by natasha romanov in the snowy setting
and natasha joins a team of
post-apocalyptic heroes that includes
captain carter party thor gamora with
thanos sword and presumably strange
supreme maybe some others but
ultravision is probably what ultron's
ultimate plan was before the avengers
interrupted him it took vision spotty
and avengers voltron because remember
ultron planned to create a new
synthesized form that would be his final
form using the vibranium infused tissue
and the mine stone and then he's going
to plug himself in but in helen's show
unplugged it and the avengers stole the
cradle
um so instead of housing jar so instead
of housing ultron's consciousness the
avengers reprogrammed and with jarvis's
ai to get vision but also thanks to the
help of a mjolnir tap like there's a lot
of ingredients that which yes
[Laughter]
but in this case we now see an ultron
looking robotic shell in casing vision's
face mine stone in the head the other
five stones on the chest plate there's a
few interesting things to talk about
here because this episode is set during
the first thor film right or around that
same time phase one i think we could say
uh an age of ultron didn't occur until
like phase two that's when thor had been
working alongside the avengers for a few
years that was in 2015. that's like four
years yeah so could ultravision be using
the time stone to go back to this moment
why like why wouldn't he go back earlier
if he's trying to kill avengers
but
then i thought maybe ultravision could
be the result of tony stark just
implementing his ultron plan earlier
around the time of iron man 2 which was
fury's big week but that still doesn't
work because stark needed the mind stone
to make ultron online to begin with so
he wouldn't have had the mind stone yet
it was still in loki's scepter which
wasn't even loki's scepter yet um but
i think it brings up the most
interesting detail this episode the
infinity gauntlet and odin's vault that
was one of the most fun easter eggs i
spotted because at first it seemed like
just a jokey shout out to how they had
the infinity gauntlet uh in thor one in
odin's background and everyone's like
whoa that was there but then marvel
later retconned that one is a fake
gauntlet when hella pushed it over in
ragnarok but if you remember that fake
version of the gauntlet was a
right-handed one and the stones had a
different configuration the blue stone
was in the middle because i think at
that point they hadn't decided which
stone was going to be which and thor won
or if they were ever going to do an
infinity stone story uh but this
gauntlet they straight up committed to
it being thanos's left-handed gauntlet
the yellow mind stone is in the middle
this is a real legit gauntlet now to me
i kind of read this as like how what if
has done this with other phase one
weirdnesses like they recast terence
howard as like the the don cheadle
version of the character in last week's
episode uh same with like edward
norton's appearance no longer exists and
what if it's just been ruffalo since the
beginning yeah so in the same way it
seems like they're doing that but it's
also just weird that this uh
gauntlet
in the main mcu timeline wasn't even
forged until e3 forged it for thanos
years later
so
i think ultimately we just have to chalk
this up too it makes no sense whatsoever
for odin to have this version of the
real actual gauntlet yet with all the
stones in it uh in the vault
unless you could argue it's another fake
one but it's just a fake one that looks
exactly like the one thanos wears so it
has less of that fakeness to write off
as a joke you know it's so confusing but
i think ultimately the only way
ultravision makes sense as if he comes
from an alternate reality
using the powers of the combined
infinity stones to do this he must have
come from a reality where ultron was
successful produced a final form with
vision and then went on to stage a
conquest for the stones before thanos
ever got to it and now he's hopping
reality to reality conquering the
multiverse and he's so dangerous that
even the watcher didn't see him coming
he was surprised
which is interesting right he's like
wait huh what so he's like
but this is a big deal empty because
like before this whenever we saw the
infinity stones combined the worst thing
that could happen would be that someone
could like erase all of life or just
destroy the the universe as we knew it
and start over uh or like bring back
half of all life but now we're like
learning new things that once you have
all six infinity stones you can do a lot
of stuff uh they you know and in this
case i think they basically turn you
into a nexus being who can transcend
realities and by this same logic staying
in the world of what if zombie thanos
after he would have attained
the mind stone would also be able to
transcend realities to spread the zombie
virus
so looking ahead to the final two
episodes i think that's the showdown
we're headed for
stone-powered ultravision in his
centuries versus stone-powered thanos
and his zombies and then the surviving
avengers assembled by the watcher caught
in the middle trying to keep the
multiverse from tipping too far to
either side of that chaos
oh my god this is like infinity war two
essentially like we're just getting more
this is like a true infinity war two
infinity powered beings going to war
while a third party tries to stop
everyone from wrecking the multiverse i
like it i dig it i really hope that's
what happens because it does seem like
they're setting that up but also what's
really interesting here is that this
sort of is a confirmation that the
infinity stones work in other universes
like it doesn't matter what unif
universe that you're in or if the stones
are native to that universe they can
just come in and it'll work apparently
so yeah that gives us hope for the
future of the mcu well not that the like
the live-action mcu needs infinity
stones but like
the infinity stones could technically
come back into the universe by through
another um from another universe yeah
it's i mean coming out of loki was a
little unclear
what the power status of the infinity
stones were it seems like in the tva tva
is kind of like a neutral ground right
so when they're in the evidence drawer
they're de-powered when they're in the
void
i mean the the drawer got pruned to the
void right so would the infinity stones
have power we've been asked about that
before my guess is no like the void the
tva the citadel at the end of time
represent stuff removed from any part of
the sacred timeline
even though the final shot of loki
season one shows reality warping as if
it were a part of a of a sacred timeline
chunk
until season two
you don't really know yet but um but i
think the i think you're right empty i
think stones can work in different
timelines i used to think that stones
have could only work if they were in the
timeline that they were attached to
originally but i think even if they go
to different
universes at least maybe that's the
difference right universes versus
timelines but it seems like at least the
rules of what if is that you can
transcend realities with those infinity
stones and they can still function like
you could still turn people into bubbles
[Laughter]
thanos is favorite thing to do with
unlimited powers like bubbles for
everyone i mean that's what i would do i
would sleep i would wake up and play
board games and then i would blow
bubbles and that's all go away with my
life i feel like what if thanos was
actually just like a really like
wholesome chill guy who liked cute
things but he's just like i just gotta
just gotta do run maintenance of the
universe real quick but after this it's
just puppies and bubbles all day long on
my farm hey i have a question mt do you
think that ultravision could have gotten
those six infinity stones from zombie
thanos that maybe there was some fight
and then like the ultron sentries
activated uh and then from there they
took out the zombies or maybe just made
like a safe zone i mean because the
zombies can't really affect an ultron
century they could affect vision you
would think right even though vision
says that he's uh an android he is a
synthesis he is made partially of human
tissue
whatever i i won't question that logic
too much but
i think that you could argue that ultron
centuries are immune to a zombie virus
and then might be able to steal those
stones from thanos in some kind of
sneaky way and maybe there was some past
war where they where they fought and
then like
zombies were supplanted by ai
no i think that that makes a lot of
sense there because like you know
zombies at the end of the day they're
still human tissue and like ultron bots
they're robots and like they're able to
take over you know the the unit for the
world in many robot apocalypse scenarios
so like why not a zombie world i feel
like it'd be very a lot easier honestly
to take over a zombie world as you know
this ultron thanos but what's really
interesting about ultravision for me and
what makes him more dangerous than like
thanos with the infinity gauntlet is
that vision is made out of a vibranium
body he has this vibranium synthesis
body so like we've seen with uh with
thanos and with tony and with the hulk
that when they snap and use the stones
it really messes them up but with vision
he has this symphysoid body made of
vibranium he could probably use the
stones repeatedly because he has a more
durable body that is made of vibranium
so like i feel like he's more of a
threat than we've ever seen
with these stones there was a question
around infinity war
about would synthesize or would people
who are mostly machine
i think if they started as a living life
form they would snap right uh the way
you know peter quill and a lot of the
guardians have like different uh
embedded things but vision died when his
mind stone was ripped out so we don't
know what would have happened like could
he snap away uh this is back when i
didn't like vision that much so my
argument was like no he's not alive he's
gonna have to watch all of his friends
die that's what robots have to do
um since wanda vision i've now i now
love vision
he's now one of my favorite characters
so i would say he now has more of a soul
and more humanity he probably would be
on the cutting block
if uh if it came to it and he could have
dusted he has more of a soul than i do
eric
oh definitely more than i do you i
believe have the soul of ten post-vision
divisions oh that means a lot to me
because i love visions and forty
pre-vision one divisions there's math in
my head for how i really journal
well before we continue guys there's
nothing sexier than confidence and
bluetooth can give you confidence when
it counts and where it counts bluetooth
is a unique online service that delivers
the same active ingredients as viagra
and cialis but in chewable tablets and
at a fraction of the cost you could take
them any time day or night so you can
plan ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days but the
best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy bluetooth tablets are made
in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discreet
package so if you could benefit from
extra confidence when it's time to
perform bluetooth can help and we've got
a special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code inside marvel at checkout just pay
the five dollars in shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code inside marvel
to receive your first month free visit
bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank blue chew for sponsoring this
episode but we also want to thank helix
for sponsoring us you know one what if
you don't want to find the answer to
what if i had a bad night of sleep on
this mattress so i don't want to know
you deserve certainty with your mattress
and helix sleep is here to deliver
because you will never have to wonder
that question with helix sleep they make
the best mattresses they have a quiz
that matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the mattress that is
perfect for you they have soft medium
and firm mattresses mattress is great
for cooling you down if you sleep hot
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers i took the quiz i got matched
with the dusk luxe helix mattress
because i wanted a medium firm mattress
with lumbar support it sleeps cool i
sleep great on my helix mattress no
questions asked the mattress ships right
to your door for free you never need to
go to a mattress store ever again they
were awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gq in wired
magazine just go to helixsleep.com
insidemarvel take their two minutes
sleep quiz and they will match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
audience at helixsleep.com inside marvel
that's helix sleep.com inside marvel for
up to 200 off and two free pillows and
we want to thank upstart for sponsoring
this episode if you dread looking at
your credit card statement every month
upstart can help lift that weight off
your shoulders upstart is a fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment unlike other lenders
upstart looks at more than just your
credit score like your income your
employment history that means they can
offer smarter rates with trusted
partners with a five minute online rate
check you can see your rate up front for
loans between 1000 to fifty thousand
dollars you can receive funds as fast as
one business day after accepting your
loan find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com marvel that's upstart.com
marvel don't forget to use our url to
let them know that we sent you loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com marvel all
right back to the episode mt i want to
ask you what if the watcher was
surprised by ultravision because this
watcher is less perceptive than we
thought
that's actually that's actually what
caught me by surprise there and no pun
intended was because the watcher yeah
you're right because the watcher was
like wait what is this what's happening
ultron's coming and like i assumed that
the watcher would just be able to see
everything and know everything but like
it got a it kind of made me think like
oh yeah the watcher watches the watcher
is not omniscient the watcher doesn't
know everything that's why he watches if
he knew everything then why would he
have to watch in the first place so i
was just like you know what there's i i
like how they
caught him by surprise because sort of
put some limits on his powers it's like
all right we're not dealing with this
like you know even though like the the
promo material and even the intro sort
of gives him this like eternity-esque
vibe with like you know the cosmos um it
being his body and like his eyeball
being a star like sort of like eternity
um even though he's like that and they
depict him like that he's not as you
know omniscient as eternity would be
he's just this cosmic being that watches
so i did like that and it does seem to
imply that he is left perceptive than we
originally thought but what do you think
what do you think yeah i agree i they do
these little things to humanize and
we've talked in the before about how he
just gets closer and closer and closer
every episode right
but like you also see more of his face
his skin his mouth moving he has like
kind of a flesh tone to him uh and
now this episode there's like the fact
that he's surprised i i i might be
reading into it but when he blinks like
the brightness of his eyes just fades
away for a second i'm like so this guy's
capable of blinking he doesn't see every
moment he sees the inside of his eyelids
sometimes it's just like a little
animation detail to feel like oh yeah he
blinks he's like
the fact that he blinks means he misses
things right
and uh i think the fact that he was
surprised like every other time when an
episode has like a doom ending like
zombie thanos or whatever it is the
watcher's always kind of like uh i told
you so
i told you not to do this stuff doctor
strange but this time he's like even i
didn't know this was coming so i think
at this point this just tells us that uh
the watcher is about to intervene i
think at this point he's like oh
i don't know everything
right i should probably stop some of
this stuff from transcending too many
realities because i think
the final episodes are going to be like
uh ultravision zombie thanos these other
things are going to be hopping from
reality to reality uh and destroying the
multiverse and the watcher's like well
if i have nothing to watch
i'll have to play board games
and learn the joys of wingspan
burgundy and lords of water deep not
ticket to ride that's trash
but lots of other wonderful games to
enjoy and not have to watch things
all the time right i mean if someone's
going to deactivate my interdimensional
cable you best believe i'm intervening
um that's unacceptable i want to also
ask you mt what if whatever happened on
this alpha star icarus was actually
genocide i thought that was gonna be
revealed as something this episode and
like a lot of things what if we just
kind of never addressed it again it was
just like oh yeah it was fine don't even
worry about it it was gonna explode
anyway he said it was a meteor anyway it
was already burning up we just helped
moved it along faster no one got hurt
even gary the goat got away eventually
and i thought we were gonna get answers
to like what happened there right what
do you think happened there mt i just
want to hear your fan fiction theories
for what happened to those people
actually no that's a really good
question eric because i don't really 100
know what happened there either because
they don't really go into it but i think
that
what probably happened was just that he
probably maybe just dropped the hammer a
little bit too hard or something yeah
and he's just like oh [ __ ] i may have
accidentally wrecked this whole
system thing so i don't know i think
it's probably something to do with
mjolnir
i think he told search her to break
dance and search her just started doing
some coffee grinders some windmills some
flares some backspins and just lost
sight of himself and burned that planet
faster than it was supposed to
i don't i like this episode never got
too dark where you saw people screaming
in terror uh like tourists at liberty
island who got crushed by the arm of the
statue of liberty as it fell on them
uh
but like probably some people died there
might have been people in that ferris
wheel um you know those gondolas
uh and it was never explored but people
probably died
and i wish this episode went into that
more
right like i would love to see like a
super realistic take like sort of like
invincible almost of like all the actual
casualties that happened during this
ranger because like it would have been a
really good perspective and like kind of
like made me feel like oh [ __ ] we should
really stop this party because like for
me and from our perspective it's like
let the party go on everyone's having a
good time why that's not the party
yeah yeah like uh like thor just grabs
jade foster he's like kiss line and just
starts mowing her through
[Music]
don't be afraid of it
i think the people of alpha star icarus
were slaughtered i think it was genocide
and i think had captain marvel not
intervened and had frigga not intervened
that would happen to earth eventually
too i think they need to party so much
and i think that
everyone everyone who has loud parties
on earth every uh influencer out there
who throws these ragers that's secretly
what they want to do they want to burn
the world down until james corden with
all of those uh flash mobs you know
that's what he wants to do that bastard
when he goes out on crosswalks and he
stops traffic he wants to bring cities
to a standstill that's what they're
doing they're hedonists they want to
destroy the world and we have to stop
them by making them fall in love with
wingspan exactly wingspan will save us
all
it really will i have a wingspan shirt i
wish i could wear it but it blew it
blends in with the blue background and
then i'm just a floating head like scott
lang and it freaks people out well uh
our final question what if captain
marvel couldn't lift the hammer right
would that make lady thor jane foster
technically be mightier than her
considering in thor love 11 thunder she
can wield mjolnir see i don't know
because we we did see captain marvel and
thor go head to head in this episode and
captain marvel seemed to be stronger in
terms of like you know just power um
than thor it seems so i would say on par
i don't know stronger i think she's on
par and then when mjolnir anchored her
down that was it like that was the end
of the conversation like
cap is uh worthier than her technically
vision is a coffee table is worthier
than an elevator a code
well this is true but like i guess
there's a i guess there's a conversation
that should be had about like mightiness
versus power because like you know thor
and and jane they're worthy more worthy
than captain marvel to lift up the
hammer and like the hammer is more
physically capable of like you know
keeping somebody like loki or or captain
marvel down and like on the ground but i
don't know i think that this is all has
to the mightiness has to do more with
the enchantment and the power sort of
like varies on how
you're feeling almost because like we
saw in thor ragnarok that like he was
like oh man like i gotta go super saiyan
thunder lightning mode because like i
have this weird like emotional moment
with my dad and like you know with with
hella and all that stuff and so i think
that whoever's like i feel like your
mind limits your potential in terms of
your beer power in the mcu so like i
don't know never about you just
eliminate that stuff i don't know what
i'm saying i like that theory a lot i i
just think the mcu has been very uh
nebulous about
what worthiness is it's a charm it's
odin's charm he says whoever is worthy
uh but like you know it was just thor
stopped being an [ __ ] in in for one
like cap was always
so low
at what point did cat become worthy
could skinny steve have lifted mjolnir
was he worthy was did he just is it just
having a heart of gold don't a lot of
marvel characters have hard hearts of
gold like vision seemed to be able to
lift it because he had thor's lightning
in him and that's kind of what brought
him to life
but but is it vision having a heart of
gold was it worthiness or is it uh being
um
related
in some kind of energy way to thor
it's not really clear but all we know is
that captain marvel is not considered
worthy by odin which i just think is
noteworthy this is true because like we
haven't like captain marvel wasn't
around during that uh age of ultron
let's all lift the hammer scene so like
i do like that we had that scene so we
could see which one of us is worthy but
now we know that captain marvel is not
worthy of lifting the hammer so it's
just a really fun little mcu tidbit but
we know that jane will be in thor love
and thunder she's gonna lift that hammer
she's gonna become the mighty thor i
wanna know what made her worthy uh is it
just like being in a deep powered state
is it being a hero i'm just saying
everyone in the mcu has saved a life at
some point i thought it was interesting
she got that tattoo that said mjolnir
magic you have the science microscope
and then mjolnir match yes and to me
it's like is that kind of like they got
natalie portman back to voices character
which i just find fascinating did they
go to the set of thor love and thunder
and just be like all right everyone shut
up shut up shut up okay okay uh batista
well batista i don't think was there but
uh
but like go to some of the gold bloom
goblin can you just say scoot scoot cool
cool
and he goes yeah yeah scoot scooting i'm
taking the scooter
he's like i don't know if i could say
scoot i might need to renegotiate my
contract i don't know yeah i guess my
point is like natalie portman's back in
the mcu and we know that's coming in
thor love and thunder like i feel like
some of the stuff in this episode is
like reminding us of her relationship
with thor
even though it was pretty surface level
and superficial in this episode they
even had like goofy romance music
playing when whenever you talk
[Laughter]
yeah no like i feel like a lot of this
series is just like hey remember all of
these like funny things or like all of
these things that happen in the mcu
because you're gonna have to remember
them for like the future live action
stuff that we're going to do so rather
than you know playing you all like a
best of like clip show of like here's
all the stuff that you need to remember
here's what if and then like you'll just
remember from just watching these
episodes i agree i i did find it
interesting to watch captain marvel
fight thor i like seeing them seen those
far uh and i
i captain marvel
is a character whose powers are just
kind of all over the map in terms of how
powerful she is like every time she
appears she's just essentially superman
you know and in the mcu it's like any
character like that is just like
infinitely powerful i think that was my
issue with vision at the beginning it's
just like they don't need like a
kryptonite weakness but they need to
have something that can restrain them
that isn't just a more powerful
character something in them that kind of
their unhealable wound their dramatic
flaw you know uh it can be their
arrogance like dr strange he seems to be
bound by his own arrogance uh and he's
trying to be too experimental uh peter
parker in the mcu is just naive he's too
trusting you know black widow doesn't
trust enough right like she has trouble
trusting people because she as a spy has
just been burned too many times
so i i'm always more interested in
characters flaws rather than things that
make them like just god mode constantly
right i think that
one of the flaws that they sh they could
be subtly hinting at in the mcu so far
with captain marvel is that she's a
workaholic like this woman has so much
responsibility and she's so she's
everywhere around the universe this is
sort of sort of sort of like reminds me
of a genus vel who was another captain
marvel in the comics who
in the comics she sort of goes crazy for
a little bit with all the cosmic
responsibility that he has and like he
kind of goes evil a little bit so like
we sort of see captain marvel she's like
oh man i'm the most powerful being in
the universe and i'm just like the
superman for the universe and she's sort
of like everywhere so like we always get
captain marvel on a phone call because
she's never available
empty that's such a great point yeah
because an end game she told rodie she's
like well i was trying to save other
planets and she's always headed to
somewhere else and then uh in the
shanghai post credits and she's like oh
gotta go um but like she's so far we
haven't seen her react to that it's just
kind of like gotta go but if in that
moment if brie larson was like
yeah i was
i was trying to save other planets like
like to see that regret of the doctor
who has to decide triage you know that's
a fascinating discussion of like i can
save theoretically as many lives as i
can we're going back to lost jack
shepherd he has to decide what lives to
save and that is a fascinating
discussion like which planets are
worthier of my help right now i hope the
marvel's goes into that that needs to be
part of brie because that is kind of the
superman debate that's the the dr
manhattan debate right like right right
yeah i can only i have to choose which
lives to save lex luthor made superman
and the first super donner superman
which coast of the united states to save
right and that's that's how you get them
that's how you force them to cry force
them to bleed is by watching others die
and so far we haven't seen enough good
writing for captain marvel to explore
that but i think you're right that is
need that does need to be where we go
with her oh yeah let's get into marvel's
i cannot wait for the marvels because uh
nia decosta i think that was her name
the director yeah i'm a killer director
candy man right oh man it's gonna be
great
uh well that is it for this episode of
inside marvel mt and i are gonna be back
next wednesday with our what is episode
8 reaction don't forget to check out our
many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow mt at
mastertainment follow new rockstar
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcasts thank you for watching
and we'll close with our favorite moment
of the episode did you boom no i didn't
boom did you boom you always boo i never
boom in private
[Music]
you